foreign
what I would call the pandemic of
pointless tipping now it used to be that
tipping was expected only if you were at
a sit-down restaurant or ordering a
pizza for delivery
it's a simple time back then everybody
knew the rules and expectations you were
asked to leave a tip only and very
limited and specific circumstances which
meant that uh you could you could tip
generously when those occasions or else
it was a win-win
the waiters and pizza delivery guys they
made out pretty well and you had the
opportunity to feel magnanimous I used
to tip upwards of 25 even more for most
tipping situations I was essentially a
philanthropist back in those days
but then the dam started to crack a
little bit and suddenly places like
coffee shops were putting out tip jars
and uh you know why do I need to tip
someone for pouring me a coffee I could
do that by myself I'm more than happy to
let me behind the counter I'll handle it
nobody ever bothered to justify the
coffee shop tip jar and we didn't have
time to stop and think about it because
next thing you know sit down restaurants
started offering to-go options but they
still wanted tips even for that we used
to tip the waiter for serving the food
now we're being asked to tip the guy who
simply hands a bag of food across the
counter and we got to tip the same for
that we're told tipping had already
gotten out of hand and we hadn't seen
the worst of it yet because one day
seemingly out of nowhere all at once
every store in America started using
touch screen tablets at checkout which
makes it uh even easier to add a tipping
option and this was the moment when the
dam finally gave way the simple innocent
days of tipping only on pizza night or
date night were gone and now everybody
wants a tip every cashier at every store
suddenly turns into a panhandler doesn't
matter if you're at a bakery or a coffee
shop or a fast food place or an airport
or a supermarket or gas station a
hardware store they all want tips
they've all decided that inflation
hasn't made life expensive enough as it
is apparently
and even as these industries
intentionally make their already too
expensive goods and services even more
expensive the quality of the goods and
services declined
the website retail retail customer
experience.com reported last year on a
poll of over 96 000 consumers which
found that the quality of customer
service has dipped dramatically so if
you've noticed a significant increase in
the number of customer service workers
who are totally disinterested and
generally incompetent and often openly
angry at you for walking into their
establishment to begin with that's not
your imagination
like we've all noticed the same thing
and yet at this precise moment when
service has never been worse
we're being asked to pay more than we
ever have for it
but at least if you're tipping a um
you know Sullen and lazy Customer
Service employee you're still tipping an
actual employee you're tipping someone
you're tipping a human being
increasingly even that is starting to
change the Wall Street Journal reports
this week quote quote tipping at
self-checkout has customers crying
emotional blackmail
zero interaction with employees during a
transaction no longer guarantees freedom
from the moral quandary of how much to
tip prompts to leave 20 at self-checkout
machines at airport stadiums cookie
shops cafes across the country are
rankling consumers already inundated by
the proliferation of tip screens
business owners say the automated cues
can significantly increase gratuities
and boost staff pay but the unmanned
prompts are leading more customers to
question what exactly the tips are for
they're cutting labor costs by doing
self-checkout but what's the point of
asking for a tip and where is it going
says Ishita Jamar a senior at American
University in Washington DC who has
noticed more self-serve tip cues at
restaurants she frequents tipping
research tipping researchers that's a
job apparently tipping researchers and
labor Advocates say that so-called tip
tip creep is a way for employers to put
the onus for employee pay onto consumers
rather than raising wages themselves
companies say that tips are an optional
thanks for a job well done
job well done well who did the job at a
self-checkout machine me
if anyone should be tipped after I use
self-checkout it should be me and I
really should get a tip because I'm very
efficient on the uh on the self-checkout
okay unlike a lot of people and they're
in front of you self-checkout you know
that's going to be a problem it's gonna
be there they bag each thing slowly and
individually and all that I I speed
through that thing
it's one of my it's one of my best
skills
and I've already taken on the role of
the employee when I'm at the
self-checkout machine I am scanning and
bagging my own items
so the the store should be tipping me
for my labor not the other way around
president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
if I could do a trump impression here I
would do it but I can't so our currency
is crashing and will soon no longer be
the world standard which will be our
greatest defeat frankly in 200 years
there are three reasons the central
banks are dumping the US dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars political economic upheaval
dating all the way back to Biblical
times and that is gold I've bought gold
from Birch gold in preparation for
uncertain Economic Times and you can
trust them too you can now own golden a
tax sheltered account retirement account
from that with the help of Birch gold
that's right Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold the best part is you don't
pay a penny out of pocket the currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does a dollar have you can protect
your savings with gold Birch gold is an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau they have thousands of happy
custom I'm one of them if you want to be
one of them you can text Walsh to
989-898 to get your free info kit on
gold again text Walsh to
989898 today
self-checkout has always been kind of a
time of internal emotional Conflict for
me because on the one hand
I appreciate how self-checkout caters to
my anti-social Tendencies so I like that
I don't have to talk to anybody that's
great on the other hand I think it's
certainly a generally unhealthy thing
for society to replace human human jobs
with machines I don't think that's a
good Trend okay it doesn't go anywhere
good
and besides I sort of resent being asked
to do the job of an employee without
being paid for it I think assumergate to
the point where Walmart expects the
customers to come in at 3am to unload
the trucks and stock the shelves and mop
the floors and they'll still ask us to
leave a tip at the end of it and most
people will see that's the real story
here
you know it's clear that the Tipping
virus
it's spreading uncontrollably we all
know that now as with most things in our
culture the solution is to get back to
the basics to return to tradition the
only people should be asking for a tip
are Waiters
and fast food delivery people
even though the food delivery apps
already charge service fees and delivery
fees and delivery service fees and
Service delivery fees and then they ask
for a tip on top of all that so you're
paying 87 for a hamburger before you add
the tip that's kind of a separate issue
um waiters and delivery people still
they can ask for tips
a few other service jobs that have been
grandfathered in valets coach checks Etc
everyone else can make do with the wage
that they're already being paid they're
already getting paid to do your job
that's why if you're at the checkout
your your paycheck is for this right
here this interaction where I'm giving
you something you're scanning it you're
taking the card like that's what that's
for that's what your paycheck is for
that
and that's how it used to be and it's
how it should be again
we can get we can get back there
but it's up to the customers to make
that happen the customers have to say no
see this is the other element in the
perfect storm that has led to this
tipping pandemic most people in our
culture they don't know how to say no
they were never told Noah's kids they
never tell their own kids no they never
tell anyone though they tolerate
everything they accept everything and
they leave a tip whenever the prompt
comes up because they they don't want to
say no in that context either
we have to recapture the long lost art
of saying no
as much as I complain about the
proliferation of tipping I'm really
complaining on behalf of all of those
people who are suckered into it because
it's not actually a problem for me
personally I have no trouble saying no I
will hit the no tip option on the
checkout prompt without feeling the
slightest tinge of guilt
okay even if it's one of those things
where they they really ran ramp up the
emotional blackmail but by asking you
sometimes if you're in maybe say a a
drive-through line and they'll say oh
did you want to add the tip here
like probably 90 of people in especially
then will say oh yeah sure I'll do I
have no problem saying oh no I don't
thank you for the opportunity I don't
I'll just pay I'll pay the actual amount
that's on the receipt and that's it I uh
thank you so much for the opportunity to
pay more but I would I'd rather pay less
actually
I'm not stealing the goods that I
purchased I've already paid for them I
don't feel morally compelled to
voluntarily pay more than what they cost
because that's what the tip prompt is
really asking here's your total would
you like to make it more expensive
no I would not like that no thank you
that's all that's all we need to say
and saying no to tip to the tip prompts
is just to start it's good practice for
all the other no's we should be saying
emotional blackmail is a common tactic
in our society and it's used to advance
all sorts of Insidious agendas
the over tipping agenda is is not the
most Insidious but it's not the least
either
and the solution is the same either way
just say no
and to those asking for undeserved tips
we can also say you're canceled
and I'll do it for the show this portion
shows a move over to members block you
become a member today by using Code
walls to check out for two months free
on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed